[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا ونحن في هذه التغطيه على
العربيه
مستمرون بهذه التغطيه للمحاكمه التاريخيه
محاكمه القرنه وهي محاكمه الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب اذا مشاهدينا دونالد ترامب
هو رهن الاعتقال الان حتى يتم الافراج عنه
بكفاله ترامب ومنذ لحظات خروجه من برجه
وصولا الى محكمه منهات اراد الظهور قويا
منتصرا امام مؤيديه امام الاعلام بشكل عام
وهو الان يتحضر للمثول رسميا امام المدعي
العام في منه طبعا قبيله دخوله المحكمه
وصفت ترامب اعتقاله بالحدث السرياني قائلا
انه لا يستطيع ان يصدق ان هذا ما يحصل في
امريكا
الرئيس السابق المتهم طلب ان يتم التقاط
صوره جنائيه له خلال اعتقاله لكن طلبه قبل
بالرفض فورا تحسبا لعدم استغلالها هذه
الصور او غيرها لدعم حملته الانتخابيه في
عام 24
اذا مشاهدينا نحن ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور
من امام مقاعد المحكمه التي سيمثل فيها
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بعد قليل طبعا
في الايام الماضيه كان الحديث عن ان هذه
المحاكمه ستكون في الساعه 18
والربع بتوقيت جرينتش اي تقريبا بعد ربع
ساعه من الان اذا كان هذا التوقيت دقيق
الان ينضم الينا محكمه منهاتن الجنائيه
مدير مكتب العربيه في نيويورك طلال الحاج
طلال اهلا بك معنا ماذا لدينا من جديد كيف
هي الصوره لديك
بالفعل ميسون سيمثل الرئيس السابق
خلال نصف ساعه القادمه ربما ربع ساعه
وربما نصف ساعه امام القاضي اخوان مارشن
الذي سيرفع السريه على التهام مواجهتي
اليه بعد كسر الشمع الاحمر لملف الاتهام
الاجراءات داخل قاعه المحكمه ستكون مقتضبه
وقد لا تستمر لاكثر من عشرين دقيقه فلا
تتوقعوا برثولا داخل هذه المحكمه
سيطلب قاضي من الرئيس ترامب
القول فيما اذا كان يريد ان يقرا عليه هذه
التهم ونرجح ان رئيس الامريكي سيكتفي
بالحصول على نسخه من هذه التهم وكذلك
محاميه حتى الان المحامين لم يحصلوا على
نسخه من هذه
التهم ترامب عينه محاميا رئيسيا اخر الى
جانب جوتا كوبينا واسمه توب بلانش ولذلك
لديه الان محاميين رئيسي ومعهم فريق كبير
من المحامين
سينصبون على دراسه جميع التفاصيل فيما
يتعلق بالاتهامات الموجهه الى ترامب بعد
تقديم وبعد ذلك يعدون لتقديم جميع
التحديات القانونيه المتاحه امامهم ضدها
او سيطلبون من القاضي اخوان
ميرشن كذلك وكذلك من محكمه الاستئناف
العليا صرف هذه التهم الجنائيه لانها تهم
على حد قولهم مسيسه وان هذه الاتهامات
الجنائيه تجعل من النظام القضائي جناء
الجنائي سلاحا سياسيا يستخدم في ضد
السياسيين وكبار الشخصيات والحملات
الانتخابيه
كما تعرفون لن يعتقل اليوم كما يردد
الكثير من الناصري هنا
المحتشدين حولنا وكذلك من
حقيقه
وسيذهب بطاريته الخاصه عائدا الى مره لاجو
بعد الظهر اليوم وسيلقي بالخطاب الذي وعد
به في ولايه فلوريدا حول تجربته مع
المحكمه الجنائيه العليا في نيويورك
الساعه 8:15 مساء الثانيه عشر والربع بعد
منتصف الليل بتوقيت جرينتش وسيصف المحكمه
بان محكمه مسيسه تدار من قبل قاضي ومدعي
عام يكون ناني له الكراهيه والحقد اذا
اردنا ان نتحدث ايضا عن الاجراءات الامنيه
يعني هناك تخوفات كبيره من اي فوضى من اي
مناوشات من الممكن ان تحصل الى جانب هذه
المحكمه من خلال وجودك هناك ومراقبتك كيف
يمكن ان تصف لنا الاجراءات الامنيه هناك
هل هناك من مناصرين للرئيس ترامب باعداد
كبيره متواجدين الى جانب مبنى هذه المحكمه
نعم في الحديقه امامي هنا بضعه الاف من
المناصرين له يرفعون اعلام
لنجعل امريكا عظيمه عظيمه اخرى
وايضا من مناوي ترامب
وكان هناك احتكاك في الصباح الباكر بين
المجموعتين وتمكنت الشرطه من فض هذا
الاحتكاك وهم يعني الحديقه مقسمه الى
قسمين بعضهم للمناويين بعض الجزء الاول
المناوين والجزء الثاني
للمناصرين عمده مدينه نيويورك يقول وهو
اسمه اريك ادمز يقول انه لا توجد هناك
تهديدات ملموسه لمدينه نيويورك او سكانها
هنا جميع افراد الشرطه في نيويورك وعددهم
طبعا يفوق سته وثلاثين الف شرطي بالاضافه
الى الشرطه السريه
الاستعداد للتعامل مع اي احداث شغب او
تهديدات من اي
الجهاز الشرطه يتوقع الاسوء دائما لذلك هم
باعداد كبيره وفي حافلات ينتظرون اذا حصل
شغب هنا بالرغم من هذه التصريحات المطمئنه
من عمده المدينه
حتى
الشركات الاعلاميه هنا التي جاءت لتنقل
هذه الاخبار عندما علمت بوجود مظاهرات
احضرت ومعها اقنعه حاميه او واقيه من
الغاز المثير للدموع في حاله وقوع
اضطرابات هناك خشيه من وقوع اضطرابات
دائما احداث السادس من يناير عام 2021 في
الاذهان
وجميعنا هنا نامل ان تظل هذه المظاهرات
سلميه ولكن المنطقه كما تفضلتي محاصره
تماما مع اغلاق الشوارع عندما قدمت ترامبو
والطائرات العموديه
فوقنا حتى الان
مع تركيب اعداد كبيره من الكاميرات لرسلي
تحركات الجميع في هذه المنطقه بالاضافه
الى زياده عدد دوريات الحراسه في المنطقه
المحيطه بالمحكمه واستخدام الاجهزه
الكاشفه عن المعادن خشيه حوزه اي من
المتظاهرين للسلاح لا يريدون تكرار ما حدث
امام الكونغرس الامريكي في السادس من
يناير عام 21
طلال ابقى معي سنتابع ايضا هذا الفيديو
الذي يظهر المسافه التي قطعها موكب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب من برجه في
وسط نيويورك الى قاعه المحكمه طبعا في
منهاتن هذا الفيديو يظهر كما هو محدد
مشاهدينا الى موكب ترامب في المنطقه
الخلفيه لبرج ترامب وهو يستعد ليقل الرئيس
السابق الى قاعه المحكمه نتابعه
المشاهدين نعود ونذكر بانه هذه الصور هذا
الفيديو هي للمسافه التي قطعها ترامب من
موكب الرئيس طبعا الامريكي دونالد ترامب
من برجه في وسط نيويورك الى قاعه المحكمه
في منهاتن كما اجتبعنا منذ قليل في هذا
السهم هو الذي يظهر موكب ترامب في المنطقه
الخلفيه لبرج ترامب وهو يستعد ليقل الرئيس
السابق الى قاعه المحكمه اذا هناك صور
هناك فيديوهات طبعا ارسلت لهذا الموكب
الذي نقل الرئيس السابق الى محكمه منهاتن
حيث من المرتقب ان يمثل امام القاضي خلال
دقائق معدودات
وطبعا الكل يعني كل العيون حقيقه وليس فقط
في الولايات المتحده شاخصه على هذا المبنى
مبنى المحكمه في منهاتن متابعه هذه
المحاكمه التي وصفت بالتاريخيه لانه لم
يسبق ان قد قد حكم رئيس للولايات المتحده
او حتى رئيس سابق انما كان هناك ايضا
البعض يعتبر بانه ليس الاول الذي يمثل
امام المحاكمه او يحاكم وانما عام 1872
ايضا كان هناك رئيس ايضا
تمت محاكمته ولكن لم يعلن عن ذلك الا بعد
سنوات عديده على كل حال نحن ما زلنا نتابع
هذا الفيديو
للموكب الذي نقل الرئيس ترامب الى قاعه
المحكمه زملائنا ما زالوا معنا بيان غانم
معي من واشنطن اهلا بك معنا طبعا الكل
يرتقب في هذه اللحظات ان يبدا مثول الرئيس
ترامب امام القاضي في محكمه من هاتا وانما
في واش نطن ما هي ردود الفعل كيف يتعاطى
الاعلام ما هي المواقف السياسيه من قبل
الجمهوريين او الديمقراطيين التي يبدو حتى
الان يلزمون الصمت
اعتقد ان الموقف الاهم هو موقف البيت
الابيض قبل قليل كريم جانفيير المتحدثه
باسم البيت الابيض اكدت ان الرئيس
الامريكي يهتم بقضايا اخرى وهو لا يفكر
بقضيه وما يتبعها اكلت مره اخرى ان هناك
بعض المعلومات عن الاوضاع على الارض ولكن
ليس هناك قلق من اضطرابات بالاضافه الى
هذا وذاك عادت واكدت مره اخرى ان الرئيس
الامريكي والبيت الابيض ليس لهم اي علاقه
بالمسار القانوني لما يحدث في نيويورك
وكررت مقالته الاسبوع الماضي وهو ان
الرئيس بايدن عرف من الاعلام مثل كل
الامريكيين ان هناك بالفعل ادانا قد وصلت
اليها هيئه المحلفين في مدينه نيويورك
بالاضافه الى ذلك نحن الان في واشنطن من
الواضح ان الاعلام الامريكي قد انه يعطي
بالفعل مساحه 100% لهذه التغطيه هذا امر
مهم جدا بالنسبه لدونالد ترامب خصوصا ان
هذه القضيه على رغم كل ما نشاهده ليست هي
القضيه الاكبر او الاهم القضيه الاكبر
والاهم سوف تكون نتيجه التحقيقات التي
تجريها وزاره العدل الامريكيه حول علاقته
بالمتبرنين الذين ذهبوا الى مبنى الكونغرس
يوم 6 يناير وبالتالي سوف ينتقل مره اخرى
الانتباه من مدينه نيويورك الى مدينه
واشنطن في هذا الوقت الجمهوريون يقفون الى
حد كبير جدا الى جانب الرئيس السابق
يعتبرون ان هذا استعمال من قبل
الديمقراطيين لوسائل القضاء لاغراض سياسيه
الرئيس ترامب يعتبر الامر انه هو ذاته
ويريد ان يستفيد منه الى اقصى حد بالنسبه
لما يقولها الرئيس ترامب ومناصريه وايضا
محاموه بان ما يحصل هو اضطهاد سياسي وكما
ذكرت الان ابيار
حول هذا الموضوع ولكن
هل
حقيقه هناك قناعه لدى اغلبيه الامريكيين
بان ما يحصل مع الرئيس ترامب هو اضطهاد
سياسي وبانه لو لم يترشح الى الرئاسه في
عشرين اربعه وعشرين لم تكن هذه المحاكمه
الاحصاءات تشير الى التالي الديمقراطيون
ان ما يحدث هو مجرد مسار قانوني
الديمقراطيون يشكلون حوالي 30% من
الامريكيين الجمهوريون ويسكنها ايضا حوالي
30% من الامريكيين يعتبرون ان هذا اضطهاد
سياسي المستقلون منغصبون الى حد كبير جدا
ولكنهم يشككون بالفعل على ان الديمقراطيين
يستعملون القضاء لملاحقه شخصيه سياسيه من
حزب من الحزب الجمهوري ما يفوت
الافراد عاده هو ان ما نشهده اليوم هو
المرحله الاولى من اعلان الاتهامات
المحكمه سوف تاتي بعد حين وايضا هناك امر
لا يشددون عليه على الاطلاق هم يشددون
كثيرا على ان المدعي العام في منهاتا هو
ديمقراطي يشددون على ان اغلبيه المنخرطين
في وضع لائحه الاتهام هم من الديمقراطيين
ولكن الامر الاهم في هذه المحاكمات هو ان
لائحه الاتهام اقرها اقرتها هيئه محلفين
مستقله وايضا سوف تكون المحكمه ليست على
يد قادم ديمقراطي ابو دعي عام ديمقراطي
ولكن سوف يكون هناك ايضا هيئه محلفين وهذا
ما يضمن المسار الجيد للعداله لذلك طلب
دونالد ترامب قبل قليل ان يتم نقل المحكمه
من منحاه الى مكان اخر في نيويورك هو
اعتبر ان هيئه المحلفين سوف تكون الاقرب
بالنسبه اليه ولكن تم رفض هذا الطلب هل
نتوقع ان يبقى ترامب ومحموها مصرين على
هذا الامر
سوف يتابع الرئيس ترامب طبعا الاصرار على
هذا الامر ولكنه ليس بالضروره ان يصل الى
ما يريده يستطيع ان يذهب الى هيئات قضيه
قضائيه اعلى سلطه ويجب ان يثبت امام
القضاء الاعلى على ان هذه المحكمه لن تكون
محكمه عادله بالنسبه له تاجيل هذه الامور
سوف يكون من مصلحته لانه اولا لتعيين وقت
لهذه المحاكمات اي للجلسات سوف ياخذ هذا
الوقت حتى الصيف ولو تاخر اكثر من الصيف
تكون دخلنا في مرحله الانتخابات الامريكيه
وحتى تنتهي المحاكمه ربما كنا نكون قد
انتهينا من الانتخابات وبالتالي يريد
بالفعل دونالد ترامب بحسب اكثريه الاشخاص
الذين هم قريبون من تفكيره يقولون انهم
بالفعل يريد ان يؤخر هذه المحاكمات ويريد
ان يؤخر اي محاكمه اخرى الى ان تنتهي
المرحله الانتخابيه اولا يختبر كونه
اعذرني ولكن البعض يعتبر بانه هذه
المحاكمه وكنت ذكرت يعني منذ قليل انه من
الممكن ان يكون هناك محاكمات اخرى
واخطر والبعض يعتبرها بانها تهم سوداويه
اكثر من هذه التهمه ستؤثر هذه الامور على
فعاليه حملته الانتخابيه يعني اذا استمرت
وزادت هذه المحاكمات
ستؤثر على حملته الانتخابيه والبعض الاخر
يعتبر بانه على العكس سيستفيد جدا
الداخل الامريكي سوف يقرر في هذا الموضوع
اولا في الحزب الجمهوري ما شهدنا خلال
العشره ايام الماضيه هو الى حد كبير جدا
الثبات في استطلاعات الراي يتقدم دونالد
ترامب ب 40% من تاييد الجمهوريين في مقابل
حوالي العشرين بالمئه
لمنافسه الاقرب حاكم فلوريدا ديسمبر اما
بالنسبه لباقي المرشحين مثل بانز
ونكههيلي وغيرهم فانهم لا يحصلون على اكثر
من على المقاطعه ولكن ام بي سي اعذرني على
المقاطعه ام بي سي تقول بان مدعي عامه
يواجه ترامب في المحكمه اذا حسب ام بي سي
مدعي عاما هاتا يواجه ترامب في المحكمه هل
هذا يعني بيار بانه المحكمه بدات
هذا يعني ان الجلسه بدات بمعنى ان دونالد
ترامب موجود داخل القاعه القاضي موجود
وايضا المدعي العام يجب ان يقدم المدعي
العام هذه الاتهامات لدونالد ترامب
اليك لمتابعه ما كنت تتحدث عنه عن موضوع
الاحصائيات وتاثير هذه المحاكمه ان كان
على الجمهوريين او الديمقراطي والانتخابات
بشكل عام ولكن ساذهب مره جديده الى محكمه
من هاتن الجنائيه ينضم الينا من هناك
ويبقى كان بقي معنا مدير مكتب العربيه في
نيويورك طلال الحاج طلال اعود اليك حسب ام
بي سي مدعي عام يواجه ترامب في المحكمه
ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل هل بدات هذه المحكمه
وماذا سيجري الان
نتوقع ان تكون المحكمه قد بدات او ليست
محكمه هي قراءه التهم تسمى بالانجليزي
اي محاكمه هي توجيه التهم الى المتهم وبعد
ذلك اما يحبس واما يخرج بكفاله ونتوقع
طبعا وبكل تاكيد ان يخرج
بكفاله ويتوجه الى
في ولايه فلوريدا القضيه
ستستانف ويطلب
جهاز المحاماه ان تصرف هذه التهم لانها
مسيسه وزائفه وهذا في الغالب ما سيقول هو
ترامب للقاضي عندما يقول انه انسان بريء
تماما من هذه التهم وانها زائفه ومسيسه
وقد ترفع الى المحكمه العليا للاستئناف
حتى قبل صدور الحكم يعني من البدايه من
الان حتى
تنظر فيها وربما تقبل في الغالب انها
ستقبل بهذه
بالنظر في هذه في هذا الطلب وحينها سوف
يتاخر الامر شهرين او ثلاثه اشهر قبل ان
تصدر قرارها هذه ما اذا كانت هذه
التهم عادله
ومنطقيه ام انها مسيسه ومزيفه كما يقول
طلال متى تبقى ان نعرف تفاصيل عن اللائحه
الاتهام موعد بدء المحاكمه يعني البعض
يعتبر بانه او سمى هذه اللائحه لائحه
الاتهام المبهمه متى نتوقع ان نعرف ماذا
في تفاصيلها ماذا فعل
بعد خروج بعد خروج ترامب من المحكمه توقع
ان تنتشر او تسرب هذه من الدفاع او من
ادعاء العام
لعامه الشعب
والجهات الاعلاميه والشبكات التلفزيونيه
اعذرني ايضا طلال الان اي بي سي نيوز
تقول بانه تم اخذ بصمات ترامب وتمت
معاملته كمتهم جنائي اذا حسب اي بي سي
نيوز تم اخذ بصمات ترامب وتمت معاملته
كمتهم جنائي وهو طبعا قيد الاعتقال الان
وحتى يتم الافراج عنه بكفاله
وفيما بعد ايضا ستستكمل هذه
المحاكمه للبعض يعتبر بانها من الممكن ان
تاخذ شهور طويله ساعود اليك طلال تفضل
نعم في اود ان اضيف نقطه مهمه هذه القضيه
عاده
تعتبر جنحه لا تعتبر الجريمه ويعاقب عليها
رجل الاعمال
[موسيقى]
بغرامه ماليه لانه كذب في
كيفيه صرف الاموال التابعه للشركه لان
ترامب قال ان هذه الاموال دفعت الى مايكل
كون لانه قدم خدمات استشاريه قانونيه الى
هذه الشركه عاده غرامه ماليه ولكن هنا في
نيويورك ولايه نيويورك بالذات هناك قانون
يسمح بتحويل التهم
والجنح الى جنايات اذا كان
اذا كان الجنايه ارتكبت لاخفاء الجريمه
والجريمه هنا هي تاثير على على الراي
العام
الامريكي اثناء انتخابات رئاسيه
محوريه
وادين بهذا الشيء ذاته مايكل كون وذهب الى
السجن ثلاثه عشر شهرا واقامه جبريه في
منزله سنه ثلاث سنوات لذلك ما ينطبق على
مايكل او غير مايكل ينطبقه على الرئيس
نفسه القانون فوق الجميع هذا ما يجادل به
الديمقراطيون ولكن هذه القضيه هي من اضعف
القضايا التي ينظر فيها
مجلس الشيوخ يقول بانه سيحصل الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب على محاكمه عادله
يعني هناك اصرار من قبل الديمقراطيين بانه
هذه المحاكمه هي محاكمه عادله وبانه لا
تدخل للسياسه بذلك بعكس ما يقول الرئيس
ترامبا وانصاره ومحاميه بان يتعرض لاضطهاد
سياسي
نعم نعم
اكمل كلامي بانه هناك تحقيقات هامه اكثر
اهميه من هذه القضيه تقديم رشوه الى ممثله
اباحيه هذه التحقيقات من قبل وزاره العدل
محاوله تغيير نتائج في ولايه جورجيا مثلا
حين اتصل ترامب المسؤول عن الشؤون
الداخليه للولايه طالبه منه خلق نحو 11
الف صوت لصالح ترامب في انتخابات 2020
لتمكيله بالفوز من هذه الولايه وكان حديثا
مسجلا مع هذا المسؤول وسمعناه جميعنا وفي
نفس الموضوع تحقق السلطات في ولايه جورجيا
في هذا ومن المتوقع ان ترفع قضايا ضد
الرئيس السابق في محاكم الولايه ولايه
جورجيا وربما ايضا في واشنطن نفس القضيه
نشري الادعات الكاذبه بان كم من كبيره من
تزوير الاصوات الانتخابيه ارتكبها
الديمقراطيون وغير النتائج النتائج لصالح
جو بايدن يتم في تحقيق هناك تحقيقات سائره
في وزاره العدل حول الكم من الوثائق
السريه التي اخذها معه الرئيس السابق الى
منزله في فلوريدا وتم اكتشافها لاحقا كل
هذه يعتبرها الخبراء قانونيين انه سيواجه
قضايا اخرى في المحاكم الامريكيه ثلاثه او
اربعه قبل حلول نوفمبر عام 2024 حيث
الانتخابات العامه
وان هذه القضيه هي البدايه وتاريخيه
بالفعل ولكنها من اضعف القضايا الاخرى على
كل حال دائما ستكون معنا طلال ساذهب الان
الى زميلتنا ايضا ريتا سليمان من امام
الكونغرس ريتا كنا تابعنا منذ قليل على
شاشه العربيه بعد المواقف لزعيم
الديمقراطيين الذي قال بان ترامبسا يتمتع
بمحاكمه عادله وبقال بان النظام القضائي
الامريكي لتاثير عليه ماذا لدينا من مواقف
جديده ماذا لديك من جديد
طبعا
التصريح الذي اعلنه تشاك تشومر زعيم
الديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ ليس بجديد
تصريح دائما ما ثبر عليه الديمقراطيون
الممثلين في مجلس النواب وايضا مجلس
الشيوخ يصرون دائما على انا لا احد فوق
القانون حتى ولو كان رئيس الولايات
المتحده
القانون فوق الجميع ويجب محاكمه الجميع ان
اخطاوا هذا بالضبط ما يحاول الديمقراطيون
تصويره ولكن الجمهوريون هم متحدون وراء
الرئيس ترامب بهذه القضيه الجميع يعتبر
بانه ما يحصل خطا كبير وليس من الممكن ان
تتم محاكمه رئيس سابق للولايات المتحده
بهذا الشكل هناك تصريح ايضا للسنه
للجمهوري ماركوربيو الذي اعتبر بانه ما
نشهده اليوم
تاريخيه وسنندم وستندم الولايات المتحده
عليه
لفترات طويله مقبله كل هذه التصريحات
للجمهوريين دائما ما تتبع بانه على الرغم
من كل ما يتم الان في نيويورك من
سابق ولكن يشددون على انه لا يجب التظاهر
واستخدام العنف بالتظاهرات
لا زالوا يكتفون بهكذا تصاريح
بدعمهم للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب ينسون
خلافاتهم معه العديد من الجمهوريين لديهم
طبعا خلافات مع الرئيس ولكنهم الان في هذه
القضيه ينسونها ويدعمونه حتى النهايه ويجب
ان نذكر هنا ميسون بانه ما يحصل الان في
نيويورك لقد تمت تم تصميمه وهندسته بكل
دقه وعنايه من قبل فريق الرئيس ترامب
لاستخدامه في طبعا في المستقبل وفي اي
حمله حم الانتخابات مقبله له
تحيه
المواطنين بعد خروجه من السياره ودخوله
الى المحكمه اي ابتسامه
يقوم بها الرئيس ترامب وحتى طلبوا بالحصول
على صورته الجنائيه كان الهدف من وراءها
بحسب الخبراء بانه سيتم استخدامها في
حملته لاظهاره بانه هو المظلوم هو
الباديه الذين يحاولون اضطهاده وهذا ما
الان عن هذه الحمله الانتخابيه وايضا نحن
سنتابع هذه الصوره
لتيشرت التي تحمل صوره للرئيس ترامب مكتوب
عليها
وهي تباع حقيقه ب 47 دولارا
وهذا دليل بانه حمله الرئيس ترامب هي مصره
على الاستفاده من كل لحظه خلال هذه
المحاكمه
تاريخ هذه المحاكمه الذي يحصل التي تحصل
في هذه الاثناء اذا هذه هي التيشيرت التي
تحمل صوره الرئيس ترامب مع التاريخ واسمه
لتاريخ هذه المحاكمه وتباع ب 47 دولار
حمله ترامب حمله ترامب استفادت كثيرا من
هذا التاريخ طبعت عده
لوجوهات على تصاميم على
التيشرتات وحتى على القبعات وعلى اكواب
القهوه والشاي ايضا وتبيعها
بارقام صحيح
يمكن
نتابع الان الرئيس ترامب الرئيس ترامب
الان نتابعه يدخل الى بل يخرج من قاعه
المحكمه ولكن لا ندري يعني الى اين يتجه
لا اعرف اذا كان زميل طلال معنا من الممكن
ان يشرح لنا هذه
الصوره والى اين يتجه من الممكن ان يكون
لديه معلومات اكثر عن هذا المبنى
وكيف هو يبدو بانه استراحه من الممكن ان
تكون لحظات استراحه للرئيس ترامب كنا
كنا تابعناه منذ قليل يخرج من قاعه
المحكمه وكنا ذكرنا ايضا منذ قليل بان بان
في هذه المحكمه تم اخذ بصمات الرئيس ترامب
وتمت معاملته كمتهم جنائيه اذا الان الى
زميلنا طلال طلال تابعنا هذه الصوره
للرئيس ترامب ماذا لدينا من جديد
[موسيقى]
وسيتم احراز هذه الكفاله باسمه لا نعرف ما
هو حجم هذه الكفاله طبعا اكيد القاضي اعلن
عنها داخل هذه الجلسه التي لا نعرف
تفاصيلها حتى الان
وسيذهب بعد ذلك جوا الى
مارالاجو متوجها من مطارده هنا في نيويورك
اعتقد ان الجلسه انتهت وسيخرج بعد قليل من
هذا المبنى ولكنه من باب جانبي ويتوجه الى
منزله في
في ولايه فلوريدا اذا مشاهدينا
في انتظار
تفضل طلال تفضل تفضل تفضل تابع
[موسيقى]
من دفع الكفاله
يعني تكون هذه المحاكمه لليوم قد انتهت
ماذا ما هي الاجراءات التي يجب ان تتبع
فيما بعد بعد هذه الخطوه
بعد تحديد الكفاله سيتوجه الى منزله
وستكون هناك
مشاورات بين جهاز الدفاع عنه لدراسه هذه
التهم وكيف
يسمح لهم تفنيدها واحده بعد الاخرى اتوقع
ان تكون هذه الاتهامات بعدد اربعه وثلاثين
كما سمعنا من بعض المصادر وعلى كل حال هي
اكثر من ثلاثين تهمه
وسيطلبون المثول بعد ذلك امام القضاء هنا
في نيويورك لان هذه المحكمه هنا اساسها في
نيويورك لن تنقل الى مكان اخر لان القاضي
يخالف ذلك ويصر على حياه وعداله هذه
المحكمه
سيمثلون امام المحكمه
وسيطلبون كما قلت من المحكمه العليا
للاستئناف الغاء كل هذه التهم المسيسه
والمزوره اذا لم تقبل المحكمه العليا
الاستئناف
ذلك سوف يحدد موعد
لهذه المحكمه بعد شهرين او ثلاثه حيث
ستبدا محاكمه جديه بشهود وباستماع الى
ادعاء والاستماع الى الدفاع كي محاكمه في
اي مكان اخر وبعدها يقوم المحلفين يقوم
المحلفون وعددهم عشرون محلفا باتخاذ
القرار فيما اذا كان هو مذنبا او غير مذنب
وطبعا قضيه اجراميه الان او الجنائيه ويجب
الحرص على حياد هؤلاء المحلفين في واقع
العمر ترامب لديه نقطه هامه ووجيهه وهي
انه لن يحظى بمجموعه من المحلفين هنا في
نيويورك لان نيويورك معقل من معاقل
الديمقراطيين او الحزب الديمقراطي يعني في
انتخاباتي 2016 حصل فقط على نحو 16 عشره
في المئه وحصلت هيلر كلينتون على الباقي
من اصوات الناخبين هنا في عام 2020 حصل
على 26% بينما حصل على بقيه الاصوات هو
محق بان
فرصته في الحصول على
جهاز او او لجنه المحلفين
عليا محايده اصعب من اي مكان اخر ولذا
يطلب نقلها الى ستات في ولايه نيويورك وهي
تابعه لمدينه نيويورك
يقصنها عدد اكبر من الجمهوريين وفرصته في
الحصول على محلفين
يتعرفون مع قضيته اكبر
كل هذا سيحصل خلال الاشهر القادمه سنكون
معكم على تواصل باذن الله طلال يعني من
الممكن ان نعتبر بانه ما جرى اليوم هو فقط
اخذ البصمات
واعطاء لائحه الاتهام للرئيس ترامب وهنا
ودفاع ودفع الكفاله الماليه وهنا يكون
انتهى امر هذا اليوم
هذا صحيح تسمى في الحقيقه لا تسمى
اي جلب
المتهم للمثولي امام القضاء وسماع التهم
الموجات اليه واما اطلاق سراحه او اعتقاله
اذا لم يكن لديه كفاله كافيه
للدفاع ولدراسه التهم والدفاع عن نفسه هذه
واخذ طبقات الاصابع والتصوير وفيما شابه
هي اجراءات تطبق على كل معتقل في الولايات
المتحده وفقا للنظام القضائي في هذا البلد
قام بذلك الان ترامب وعلى لجنه الدفاع
التابعه له ان تدرس التهم تهمه تهمه وبعد
ذلك
محاوله ايجاد
كيفيه الرد على هذه التهم واثبات ان هذه
التهم مزوره وكاذبه وانها اض لا اكثر على
كل حال نحن بانتظار ان نتابع خروج الرئيس
ترامب او انهاءه من موضوع دفع الكفاله اذا
ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور من امام قاعه
المحكمه التي جرى اخذ بصمات الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب وايضا
المدعي العام طبعا
ابلغ
لائحه الاتهام الى الرئيس ترامب ومحاميه
ونتابع في هذه الصور الفريق الامني للرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب الذي طبعا خرج من
القاعه منذ قليل ونحن بانتظار خروجه على
كل حال حتى نتابع حتى خروج الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب ساذهب الى واشنطن الان مع
طارق الشامي المحلل السياسي استس طارق
اهلا بك معنا ما جرى اليوم اخذ بصمات
ابلاغ الرئيس ترامبا وط
بعا المحامين للرئيس ترامب بلائحه
الاتهامات والان يبدو بانه هناك دفع
الكفاله الماليه
كيف يمكن ان ننظر الى ما جرى الان وخاصه
من المواقف المتصاعده للرئيس ترامب خلال
توجهه الى هذه المحكمه
ودائما هجومه على هذه المحكمه وعلى القاضي
وعلى الديمقراطيين
يعني هو في الحقيقه جزء من سلوك ترامب
التقليدي هو لم يفعل ذلك مع هؤلاء فقط هو
فعل ذلك مع خصومه سواء كانوا سياسيين او
في السلك القضائي او في غير ذلك وبالتالي
هذا ليس بالسلوك الغريب على
دونالد ترامب ايضا يعتقد انه بذلك يستطيع
ان يقنع مزيدا من انصاره بان هذه محاكمه
مسيسه وانه بريء وليس هناك ما يدينه وانهم
يريدون اقصائهم من المشهد السياسي
ويعني وضع واهاله التراب على فوق راسه
املا في ان يفوز غيره سواء كان ذلك في
داخل الحزب الجمهوري او بعد ذلك اذا قدر
هذه التهمه يعني هي تهمه جنائيه البعض
يعتبر بانه لولا ترشح الرئيس ترامب
للانتخابات 20 24
لم تكن هذه المحاكمه لما اصروا عليها لما
اثيرت هذه التهم
هناك بالفعل من يعتقد ذلك لكن هو في حقيقه
الامر ايضا هذه القضيه تعود الى عام 2016
وكان من الممكن ان تسقط لانه هناك في
نيويورك كما يسمى بقانون التقدم الذي يسقط
التهم بعد خمس سنوات من وقعها لكن بالنسبه
الى وجود ترامب في واشنطن للفترات طويله
اي انه كان خارج نيويورك فان هذا يتيح
للادعاء العام ان يبقي القضيه وان يقسم
هذه الايام التي قضاها خارج نيويورك
وكانها لم تكن وبالتالي القضيه لا تزال
موجوده من ناحيه اخرى فانه
ترامب بطبيعه الحال هو
يعتقد انه هذه المحاكمه لن تؤدي
الى الا اذا يعني محاوله الهاء الناخبين
واهانه التراب فوق الرئيسيه حتى لا ينجح
في هذه الانتخابات خصوصا وان هناك طيار
حتى داخل الحزب الج لا يريدون ترامب ان
يترشحوا هم يريدون شخص اخر وبالتاكيد
سيكون هو اكثر هؤلاء الذين يملكون حظوظا
البعض يعتبر ايضا بان هذه التهمه هي بدايه
لتهم اخرى
ستتلاحق على الرئيس ترامب قبل حدوث
الانتخابات في العام 20 24
هل هذه التهمه تستحق ان
تغير في هذا المشهد وان تكون هي محاكمه
القرن يعتبروها او محاكمه تاريخيه لاول
رئيس امريكي او رئيس سابق تتم محاكمته هل
تستحق هذه التهمه ان تلصق
بوصف بانها محاكمه تاريخيه لاول مره تحصل
في الولايات المتحده مع رئيس امريكي
لا ادري يبدو باننا فقدنا الاتصال مع
استاذ طارق ام لا ما زلت معك تفضل تفضل
اعتقد انه تهم الاخرى يعني هناك ثلاث
قضايا كبرى كما هو معلوم قضيه اقتحام
انصار ترامب
وكذلك هناك قضيه يختص بها مدعي خاص تتعلق
بالوثائق السريه التي يتهم فيها بانه
اخفاها ثم هناك قضيه جورجيا التي هو ايضا
متهم فيها بانه لن يفهم ولكن يعتقد انه
ربما يواجه اتهاما بانه تحاول تدخل في
سياق هذه الانتخابات واتصل كما هو معلوم
من خلال المكالمه الهاتفيه التي تمت بينه
وبين سكرتير عام ولايه جورجيا في هذا
الوقت وحاول ان يغير نتيجه الانتخابات
هناك هذه التهم بالتاكيد هي اهم هي اكثر
يعني
سوف تكون جنائيه ايضا وهي سوف بالتاكيد
تضعه في موقف اكثر صعوبه قد يتم تحويل ذلك
هناك شائعات ترددت بان جورجيا بالتحديد
ربما اقترب موعدها لانهم ربما استكملوا
الاوراق القانونيه اللازمه اما بالنسبه
لنيويورك فهذا شان اخر لاننا لم نعرف بعد
ما هي طبيعه الاتهامات بالتحديد هناك
اتهام واضح فيما يتعلق
بتمويل
لاسكات
لكن في حقيقه الامر هناك اكثر من 30 اتهام
اخر لا نعرف ما هي هذه الاتهامات وهذا
القاضي بالتحديد ميرشن هو معروف عنه انه
رفض من قبل
الادعاءات من قبل منظمه ترامب بان
يقولون انها محاكمه سياسيه ورفض ذلك
وبالتاكيد سوف يرفض هذا الاتهام ايضا الان
اذا ما يعني طلبه ترامب او محاماه بذلك
وهو ايضا يسيطر على المحكمه بشكل كبير
اعذرني على المقاطعه ولكن نتابع الان هذه
الصوره للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب امام
مثوله امام المدعي العام وطبعا
المحامون محاموت الى جانبه في هذه الصوره
حيث
تمت ادلاء او تم ابلاغه بلائحه الاتهام
الموجهه ضده اذا هذه الصور او هذه الصوره
للرئيس الامريكي السابق رئيس دونالد ترامب
من داخل قاعه المحكمه بمنهتن يجاوره طبعا
فريق المحامين الذين ايضا يمثلون امامه
ويحاولون الدفاع عنه امام المدعي العامه
اعود اليك
بالنسبه ايضا يعني كما ذكرت منذ قليل انا
بان هذه
لائحه الاتهامات هذه البعض يعتبرها بانها
ليست خطيره بما يكفي لتستحق هذه الخطوه
التاريخيه
هذه ايضا صور اخرى للرئيس ترامب عندما كان
يمثل امام المدعي العام وبجواره طبعا فريق
المحامين ايضا هل تستحق هذه التهمه بان
تؤثر على الولايات المتحده لانه البعض
يعتبر بانه ستنقل هذه المحاكمه الولايات
المتحده الى مرحله اخرى خطيره وغير مسبوقه
نعم بالفعل هناك مخاوف من ان يعني يؤدي
ذلك الى مزيد من الاستقطاب السياسي بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين وبين المحافظين
والليبراليين وهذا من شانه ان يصب مزيدا
من الزيت على نار الاستقطاب الموجود
بالفعل منذ عده سنوات في الولايات المتحده
وزاد كثيرا حينما تولى رئيس ترامب السلطه
في عام 2016 لكن مع ذلك هناك ايضا فريق
داخل الحزب الجمهوري هم يريدون التخلص من
الرئيس ترامب لانه بالنسبه اليهم هم
يعتقدون انهم لن يفوزوا بالانتخابات
الرئاسيه في العام المقبل اذا كانت رامبو
هو المرشح الذي يختاره الناخبون في نهايه
المطاف
البعض يعتبر ايضا بانه لائحه الاتهام هذه
ستكون بمثابه صرخه صرخه حشد لمؤيديه
نعم هذا صحيح هي صرخه حشد المؤيدين
الحاليين وهناك بالتاكيد اللحظه الراهنه
تستوجب على الجميع الانتظار لاننا كما
يعلم الكل لا نعرف ما هي طبيعه الاتهامات
ومن الصعب ان ياخذ اي شخص يعني موقف ضد
ترامبو وهو لا يعرف ما طبيعتها لكن مع
السير المحاكمه لا نعرف ما الذي سيحدث هل
ستكون هناك مزيد من التسريبات سوف يسمح
لوسائل الاعلام بنشر تفاصيل المحاكمه كل
هذا من شانه ربما ان يغير في التوجهات لدى
الناخبين ولدا السياسيين بما فيهم خصوم
ترامب الذين ربما يرون انها سوف تكون لحظه
حاسمه ليس الانتقاد ترامب ولكن للقول بانه
بانهم هم ليسوا المتهمين ولا يواجهون
مشكلات قانونيه في حين ان ترامب يواجه هذه
المشكلات وبالتالي يختارون او يطالبون
الناخبين بان يصوتوا لصالحهم في هذه
الانتخابات بالتاكيد هناك فريق لن يتزعزع
عن مسانده ترامب حتى النهايه لانهم يؤمنون
به هذا هذه هذا الفريق هو فريق ماجا او
فريق حركه نجعل امريكا عظيمه مره اخرى هذا
الفريق يشكل نسبه كبيره من الج يعتقد انهم
يعني يزيدون بين الثلاثين والاربعين
بالمئه لكن هناك ايضا فريق اخر خصوصا
بالنسبه للنخبه السياسيه
وهؤلاء الناخبين المتعلمين وايضا سكان
الضواحي هؤلاء ليسوا ليسوا داعمين للترمبا
على نفس الدرجه التي يدعمه بها هؤلاء
الاخرين من فريق ماجا
ايضا من يتابع
مجريات قبل هذه المحاكمه قبل هذا اليوم
يعني منذ اشهر
ويتم الحديث عن هذه المحاكمه عن لائحه هذا
الاتهام ولكن دائما الديمقراطيون كانوا
حريصين على عدم التعليق على ازمه اتهام
ترامب حتى البيت الابيض ايضا حتى لم يتم
استغلالها لتحقيق مكاسب سياسيه برايك
لماذا هذا الحرص من قبل الديمقراطيين على
اعتبار انه هذه المحاكمه هي فقط خاصه
بالقضاء ولا
استغلال سياسي لها
لانه هذا لا يفيد الديمقراطيين ولا يفيد
حتى خصوم ترامب من الجمهوريين الكل يريد
ان يقول هذه محاكمه علينا ان نحترم يعني
السلطه القضائيه وهي ليست سلطه فيدراليه
هي سلطه ولايه ولايه نيويورك وبالتالي
هناك يعني رغبه في ان يكون هناك فاصل بين
السلطات والحفاظ على هذا الامر حتى حينما
بقدر عدد من اعضاء الكونجرس الامريكي
خصوصا في لجنتي الرقابه تستهرق وانت تتحدث
معي ايضا لدينا هذا الخبر العاجل على شاشه
العربيه قادما هاتن يوجه 34 اتهاما للرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب اذا 34 اتهاما وجهت
للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب من قبل قاضي
تفضل استس طارق
نعم يعني من فضلك اعيد السؤال لانني ذهبت
عن حرصه ديمقراطيين على عدم التعليق على
هذه المحاكمه على لائحه الاتهام ودائما
كان التركيز بانه هذا امر قضائي ولا
ولا استغلال السياسي او مكاسب سياسيه من
خلال هذا الاتهام او هذه المحاكمه
نعم هذا صحيح لانه كما كما ذكرنا انه هناك
رغبه في الفصل وانتظار ما سوف يقوله
القضاء واحترام ان هذه سلطه ولايه ولا يجب
ان يكون هناك تدخل بين السلطه سلطات
الفيدراليه التي تمثل الولايات المتحده
ككل وسلطه الولايه حتى حينما بدر عدد من
هؤلاء الاعضاء في مجلس النواب
باتهام المدعي العام وقالوا انهم سوف
يواجهون له استجوابا واستدعاء هو رفض ذلك
ابراج المدعي العام في نيويورك ورفض
الاستجابه بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك ايضا من
انتقد هذا الامر سواء كانوا من
الديمقراطيين او من الجمهوريه اشكرك استاذ
طارق الشامي المحلل السياسي كنت معي من
واشنطن الان اذهب مجددا الى زميلنا طلال
الحاج من امام محكمه من هاتن طلال 34
اتهاما وجهت لترامب ماذا في التفاصيل
هذا بالفعل ما اعلنا عنه قبل يومين انهم
ستكون هناك اربعه وثلاثون
اتهام موجهه للرئيس الامريكي
ولا نعرف التفاصيل بعد ننتظر لائحه
الاتهام ان تتسرب من الادعاء او جهاز
المحاماه
الى الاعلام وستتسرب الليله بكل تاكيد
وستكون البرامج والاخبار في الشبكات
الاخباريه الليله كلها تناقش هذه التهم لا
يحتاج الامر الى
ادانته بعدد كبير من التهم يعني ممكن
ايجاجه مذنبا في تهمه او تهمتين او ثلاثه
او خمسه من 34 وكلها تتعلق بسوء استخدام
اموال شركه
لصالح
مصالحي الشخصيه والتغطيه على
[موسيقى]
واخرون اما انصار مقاضات ترامب وتحدثنا
اليهم هنا اليوم يقولون ان من يجادل بان
هذه المحاكمه مسيسه ينسى ان مايكل كون
محامي
واحد اهم الشهود في هذه القضيه ضد ترامب
دخل السجن لاكثر من ثلاثه عشر شهرا وبعد
ذلك عاموا ونصف من الاقامه الاجباريه
الجبريه في منزله في عام 2018 هذا هذا
جانب وانه بسبب ازالته بنفس هذه الجرائم
التي يواجهها ترامب الان وهو سبب الوحيد
الذي لم يقدم للمحاكمه انذاك لكونه الرئيس
الامريكي وان محكمه العدل انذاك التي كانت
تابعه له لحكومته فضلت ان لا تحاكم رئيسا
امريكيا اثناء تاديته لهذا المنصب هناك
كثير من ابلغت خارج هذه المحكمه بانهم
عرضوا عليه
التخلي عن هذه التهم اذا ما انسحب من سباق
الرئاسي بينما الديمقراطيون يقولون انها
ليست محاكمه مسيسه واذا عرضنا عليه شيئا
للانسحاب سنثبت انها بالفعل محاكمه مسيسه
لاخراجه من السباق الرئاسي لعام 2024 على
كل حال الان يجب علينا شهر العربي
زعيمه تجمع الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب
تقول بان اعتقال ترامب هو امر مخزن اذا
زعيم التجمع الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب
تتحدث بان اعتقال ترامب هو امر مخزن وما
زلنا نتابع هذه الصور للرئيس ترامب الى
جانب الى جانبه طبعا
موحد من داخل المحكمه حيث كان يستمع الى
لائحه الاتهام من مدعي عاما هاتن وايضا
ترامبيان في ارش عليه شراء سكوت امراتين
هذا خبر عاجل ايضا جديد على شاشه العربيه
بان ترامب ينفي تقديم رشا لشراء سكوت
امراتين وكانت امراه ايضا مراسله العربيه
تحدثت بانه اصر على انه غير مذنب اذا
ترامب ينفي تقديم رشا لشراء سكوت امراتين
وهذه الصور ما زلنا نتابعها للرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب من داخل المحكمه ابقى معنا
ايضا طلال ولكن الان ساذهب الى هيوستن عبر
سكارت دكتور احمد الحنطي الباحث في الشان
الامريكي دكتور حنطي اهلا بك معنا الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ما زال مصر بانه غير
مذنب ونفى تقديم رشا لشراء سقوط
الامراتين هذه المحاكمه التي وصفت
بالتاريخيه ما هو تاثيرها على الشان
الامريكي بشكل عام وعلى الحسبين الجمهوري
والديمقراطي
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته طبعا
المحاكم سيكون لها تاثير اكبر على الحزب
الجمهوري من الحزب الديمقراطي لان الحزب
الجمهوري يعني سيكون ممزق بين
يعني بين مسارين بين الدعم ترامبا
والابتعاد عن داخل الحزب الجمهوري يريدون
قلب صفحه ترامب وتغطيه ولكنهم لا يجرون
على ذلك ذلكم قد يتمنون ان تفعلها لهم هذه
القضيه ولكنهم لن يفعلوا اي شيء
لتقديم مرشح اخر او لطي صفحه ترامب
فبالتالي اذا ما قدموا الدعم لا فهذا
سيضرهم في الانتخابات العامه لان كثيرا من
المستقلين ومن المعتدلين يكرهون ترم بشده
ويرفضون اي تاييد له واذا ما عارضوا ترامب
علنا او حاولوا ابعاده يعني بشكل ظاهر
وعلني عن قياده الحزب فهم سيواجهون مشكله
معنا خبير الجمهوريين يعني المؤيدين
لترامب خصوصا في الانتخابات الاوليه قد
تخرجهم يعني من الحياه السياسيه تماما
ما العمل الان بالنسبه
للجمهوريين يعني هم الان في هذا الموقف
الصعب ماذا يمكن ان يفعلوا لانقاذ هذا
الحزب وخاصه يعني حسب استطلاعات الراي
الان يبدو بانه الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب يتخطى بشكل واضح
ممثل عن فلوريدات ديسانتوس وايضا المرشح
الى الانتخابات عشرين اربعه وعشرين
لم يعلن ترشيح يعني لم يعلن الترشح بعد
وان كان يعتبر هو المنافس الرئيسي لترامب
ديسانتوس استطاع ان يثبت ان ترامب قابل
للهزيمه قبل للهزيمه المقصود داخل الحزب
الجمهوري
ولكنه لا يبدو انه قادر هو على هزيمه
ترامب ما لم يدخل مرشحين اخرين اقوى من
للساحه فتره سيكون هو مرشح الحزب بالنسبه
ايضا
للمحل البعض يعتبر بانه هذه المحاكمه هي
البدايه
وستتوالا التهم في
الايام المقبله وفي الشهور المقبله حتى 20
24 كيف سيتعاطى ايضا الرئيس ترامب
مع حملته الانتخابيه وهذه التهم التي من
الممكن ان تتوالى وتعد اكثر سوداويه من
هذه التهمه هذه تهمه جنائيه ولكن التهم
الاخرى بالنسبه لموضوع الكابيتال بالنسبه
لموضوع الغاء الانتخابات 20 20 وموقفه منا
ستكون اصعب عليه
بكل تاكيد هذه هي اسهل القضايا
سواء من ناحيه ان عقوبتها هي الاقل او من
ناحيه ان اثباتها هو الاصعب يعني احتمال
فوز ترامب البراءه في هذه القضيه اعلى من
احتمال فوزيه في القضايا الاخرى ولكن
القضايا الاخرى لم توجه بها الاتهامات بعد
وقد لا توجد الاتهامات نعرف احيانا يفتح
التحقيق ولا ينتج يعني توجيه اتهامات ولكن
غالبا ترامب سيكون اسلوبه في التعامل مع
جميع القضايا هو نفس الاسلوب محاوله
التاجيل والاطاله لتاخذ القضيه اطول وقت
ممكن
بغرض الاقتراب الانتخابات 24 حتى يصبح
يعني الموضوع حساس عندما تقترب انتخابات
يصبح من الحساس اكثر ان تحاكم يعني مرشح
سياسي وربما يعني ربما هو يامل ان يؤجرها
الى الى ما بعد ذلك على ان يفوز ويصبح
رئيسا وبالتالي يدعي وجود حصانه مطلقه ضد
كل القضايا وكل التحقيقات اشكرك من هيوستن
عبر سكاي كونت معي دكتور احمد الحنطي
الباحث في الشان الامريكي اذا مشاهدينا نع
اتذكر ببعض الاخبار العاجله ام بي سي
تتحدث عن ان لائحه اتهام ترامب تتضمن
تقديم روشه للشراء سقوط امراتين وكنا
تابعنا ايضا عاجل على شاشه العربيه
في تقديم رشا لشراء سقوط الامراتين ايضا
كنا تبعنا خلال هذه الساعه اخذ بصمات
ترامب واستماع ترامب للائحه الاتهام من
قبل مدعي عامه
من القاعه والان هي اجراءات دفع الكفاله
قبل خروجه والتوجه الى فلوريدا هذه
التغطيه مستمره على شاشه العربيه وانما
الان ننتقل الى من الزميله راويه وزميل
طاهر لمتابعه هذه التغطيه